[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen schönen guten Abend
wünsche ich Ihnen wir haben jetzt gut 20
Minuten Nachrichten für Sie natürlich
auch mit Sport von Sven mit Tennis und
Fußball und diesen Themen
Reise Außenministerin bärburg spricht
von teilweise ungesunde Abhängigkeit
Kampfjets für die Ukraine Deutschland
erlaubt Polen die Lieferung von Mick 29
Flugzeugen aus DDR Altbeständen
und Erfinderin des Minirocks ist tot die
britische
stirbt im Alter von 93 Jahren
die Spannungen zwischen China und Taiwan
haben sich ja zuletzt noch einmal
verschärft eine militärische Eskalation
bezeichnete Außenministerin Werburg
dabei als
wurst-szenario gerade für eine Industrie
und Exportnation wie Deutschland Werbung
ist gerade auf Antrittsbesuch in China
und versucht dort den Eindruck zu
zerstreuen dass die Europäische Union
uneinig sei im Umgang mit dem Land
während Steiner berichtet
es ist keine einfache Reise für Annalena
baerbock in den chinesischen
Staatsmedien wird sie als Anti
china-ministerin bezeichnet so versucht
Peking eine kritischere Haltung
Deutschlands als Position einiger
weniger Hardliner dazu stellen
150 Kilometer südöstlich von der
Hauptstadt Peking in der Hafenstadt die
Außenministerin ein deutsches
Unternehmen das Windturbinen herstellt
sie betont das Deutschland an der
aufstrebenden Weltmacht China am
wichtigen Handelspartner nicht
vorbeikommt klar ist aber auch dass wir
in einigen Bereichen Abhängigkeiten von
China haben die nicht gesund sind und
dass wir die Lehrerin die wir aus dem
russischen Angriffskrieg ziehen
natürlich auch mit Blick auf
Abhängigkeiten die wir mit China haben
ziehen müssen
das soll Teil der neuen china-strategie
Deutschland sein die gerade verhandelt
wird die deutschen Unternehmen warten
nicht auf die China Strategie die
Diskussion der der Politik in
Deutschland über China ist verstanden
worden und wird auch entsprechend
umgesetzt es wird aber nicht dazu zu
führen dass der Footprint der deutschen
Wirtschaft in China geringer wird
spätestens seit dem Besuch des
französischen Präsidenten vergangene
Woche wittert Peking seine Chance das
Europa nicht mit einer Stimme spricht
wenn es um das Verhältnis zu China geht
bärburg muss hier in China den Eindruck
zerstreuen dass ich Europa nicht einig
ist geweckt durch die Regierung von
Frankreich und sie muss den Eindruck
zerstreuen dass sich Deutschland nicht
einig ist geweckt durch ihre eigene
durch die Bundesregierung
außerdem eine Schule besucht ist auch
die Geburtsstadt ihres Kollegen des
chinesischen Außenministers mit ihm will
sie morgen über Chinas Rolle im Ukraine
Krieg und über Taiwan sprechen
die Bundesregierung hat Polen die
Genehmigung erteilt fünf Kampfflugzeuge
aus DDR-Beständen an die Ukraine
weiterzugeben in der Regel dürfen
Rüstungsgüter aus Deutschland nur ein
Dritte abgegeben werden wenn die
Bundesregierung zustimmt Deutschland
hatte im Jahr 2002 insgesamt 22 Mick 29
Jets an Polen verkauft sie wurden in der
damaligen Sowjetunion gebaut Polen hat
bereits acht Mix in die Ukraine
geliefert die standen allerdings nicht
aus Deutschland
warum hat Deutschland jetzt die
Zustimmung erteilt ja das ist schon ein
interessanter Moment weil man sich mal
die Geschwindigkeit angeschaut mit der
das heute ging dann zeigt dass dass die
Bundesregierung sich in dieser Frage gar
nicht mehr uneins war dass es eigentlich
schon gut vorbereitet gewesen ist
der Polen wollten diese Kampfjets schon
länger liefern das hatten wir schon aus
verschiedenen Aussagen aus Polen gehört
und Deutschland wollte sich nicht
querstellen das hat man auch schon
länger raushören können aus Äußerungen
aus der Bundesregierung wie der dass
jedes Land liefern können was es für
richtig halte und heute gab es eben die
Gelegenheit diesen Worten auch Taten
folgen zu lassen innerhalb von wenigen
Stunden hat die Ampel den Antrag der
Polen durchgewunken und dass das ganze
auch ein Zeichen setzen sollte das
konnte man zwischen den Zeilen rauslesen
als bei uns Pistorius in der
Pressemitteilung hat schreiben lassen
das zeigt auf Deutschland ist Verlass
und warum liefert Deutschland dann auch
selber kämpfte
ja da gibt es in der politischen Debatte
solche und solche Kampfjets heute ging
es um fünf Kampfjets Alter russischer
Bauart von denen experten sagen dass sie
immer ganz grob gesagt in der
Basisausstattung keine großen
Auswirkungen auf den Kriegsverlauf in
der Ukraine haben und dann gibt es noch
Kampfjets moderner westlicher Bauart um
die es geht wenn immer wieder die Bitten
aus der Ukraine auch an Deutschland
gerichtet werden dass man weitere
Kampfjets braucht und benötigt und da
gibt es eben weiterhin Zurückhaltung bei
der Bundesregierung wenn auch keinen
absolutes Tabu das ist schon längst
gefallen man hört aus der
Bundesregierung immer wieder wir liefern
das was benötigt wird zu dem Zeitpunkt
zu dem es gebraucht wird und wo man es
mit den Verbündeten gemeinsam absprechen
kann also momentan ist da noch keine
Bewegung drin bei dieser Frage aber es
ist auch nicht gänzlich ausgeschlossen
dass auch dieser Schritt irgendwann
einmal folgt danke für diese Einordnung
Pentagon seit Tagen kursieren
geheimunterlage im Netz und es stellt
sich die Frage wer sie veröffentlicht
hat laut Washington Post ein junger Mann
der auf einer US Militärbasis arbeitet
die Zeitung beruft sich auf zwei
Mitglieder einer chatgruppe die
behaupten gegenüber dem Blatt der
Maulwurf habe die Unterlagen mit nach
Hause genommen und dann in einer
videospielgruppe geteilt das
Geheimmaterial beinhaltet vor allem
Erkenntnisse zum Ukraine kriegt
US-Präsident beiden äußerte sich auf
seine Irland Reise besorgt über das
Daten Leck
und Mr teven begleitet als Korrespondent
die Reise des US-Präsidenten Emma wie
sehr bringen die Veröffentlichung die
USA in Bedrängnis
sehr denn mittlerweile berichten Medien
übereinstimmen dass es sich bei dem
mutmaßlichen Tätern den 21-Jährigen Jack
t einen Soldaten auf einem
Luftwaffenstützpunkt in Massachusetts
handelt der ganz offenbar Zugang eben zu
geheimen Dokumenten hatte der sie dann
eben geteilt hat mit einer chatgruppe zu
der etwa 25 andere Personen gehörte und
der von diesen anderen Personen
beschrieben wird als ein extremer
Regierungskritiker der auch rassistische
und antisemitische Einstellungen pflegt
die Medienberufen sich dabei eben auch
Aussagen dieser anderen Chat Mitglieder
nach diesem jungen Mann wird derzeit
gefahren wird wenn sich das alles
bewahrheitet dann ist die Tatsache dass
er die Unterlagen bekam dass er sie
quasi weitergeben konnte und das daraus
erheblicher politischer Schaden
entstanden ist natürlich hochnot
peinlich für die amerikanische Regierung
und die Chef der Sicherheitsbehörden
müssen sich mit Sicherheit vor dem
Kongress auch in dieser Frage
verantworten danke schön
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius hat
heute zusammen mit
entwicklungsministerin Schulze Mali
besucht der Bundeswehreinsatz in dem
westafrikanischen Land sollen gut einem
Jahr Enden der Grund Spannungen mit der
Militär runter auch weil diese in ihrem
Kampf gegen Islamisten auf russische
Söldnertruppe Wagner setzt über die
gemeinsame Reise von Pistorius und
Schulze sind die sahelregion berichtet
Christian hübscher
Boris Pistorius und Svenja Schulze
landen am Morgen gemeinsam in Mali hier
bleibt beiden Minister nur Danke zu
sagen für eine Mission die nicht
erfolgreich endet im Juni beginnt der
Abzug der 1200 Bundeswehr Soldatinnen
und Soldaten aus Camp Castor
wir befinden uns in einem echten Dilemma
Situation in Mali ist nicht besser
geworden und trotzdem ist nicht der
Einsatz gescheitert sondern die
Bedingungen haben den Einsatz scheitern
lassen die malische Militärregierung
blockiert seit Monaten die UN-Mission
minusma so bekommt diese Bundeswehr
Drohne seit September keine Genehmigung
für Aufklärungsflüge mehr und ist
natürlich frustrierend wenn wir die
Ausbildung ja durchleben und dann in den
Einsatz kommen unseren Auftrag hier
nicht so wahrnehmen können wie wir es
eigentlich wollten ein ganzes Jahr für
den Abzug zu lang sagt die Opposition
wir sagen als Union die Sicherheit der
Soldaten muss gewährleistet sein und die
Operationsfähigkeit muss gegeben sein
beides ist nicht mehr und deswegen ist
ein schneller Abzug notwendig neues
Drehkreuz für deutsche Sahel Hilfe soll
nun das Nachbarland mega werden schon
gestern versprachen Pistorius und
Schulze hier weitere Hilfen vor allem
für die Landwirtschaft hier vor Ort zu
sein mitzuhelfen dass dem Terrorismus
der Nährboden entzogen wird das ist
enorm wichtig auch in einer kleinen
EU-Mission in Niger will sich
Deutschland beteiligen mit maximal 60
Soldaten die dann die niedrige Armee
trainieren der Bundestag muss dem noch
zustimmen
die Kritik ist groß an Matthias Döpfner
Vorstandsvorsitzender der Axel Springer
Verlagsgruppe so soll er sich unter
anderem abwertend gegenüber ostdeutschen
und muslimischen Menschen geäußert sowie
die Bild-Zeitung zu einer pro
fdp-berichterstattung aufgefordert haben
das sollen Enthüllungen der Zeit zeigen
die Einzelheiten von Christa Läpple
gleich auf zwei Seiten lässt die
Hamburger Zeit ihre Bombe platzen sie
veröffentlicht interne Mails und
Chatnachrichten aus der Springer
Führungsetage im Mittelpunkt Matthias
töpfner der mächtige
Vorstandsvorsitzende lobt Donald Trump
äußert sich demnach aber abfällig über
Rot Grün Muslime Angela Merkel und die
Ostdeutschen insgesamt die Ossis sind
entweder Kommunisten oder Faschisten
dazwischen tun sie es nicht eklig die
Schreibweise ist original Döpfner wow
also das war ja nicht ein Zitat sondern
das waren mehrere vor allen Dingen ist
es deshalb für uns zu überraschend
gewesen war ja das komplette Achse
Springer Unternehmen immer wieder
versucht auszustrahlen wir sind für ein
gemeinsames Deutschland und aus diesem
Grund ist aus meiner Sicht der als
Vorstandsvorsitz dieses Konzerns der
eine besondere öffentliche Bedeutung
auch hat überhaupt nicht mehr tragbar
ein angefragtes Interview wollte töpfner
nicht geben am späten Nachmittag hieß es
aus der Konzernzentrale schriftlich und
sie haben es gerade gesehen wir hatten
da leider Probleme technische Probleme
mit dem Beitrag wir spielen jetzt noch
einmal ab wir schauen an die Kritik die
es gibt da Matthias Döpfner
Vorstandsvorsitzender der Axel Springer
Verlagsgruppe und sein abwertenden
Äußerungen
gleich auf zwei Seiten lässt die
Hamburger Zeit ihre Bombe platzen sie
veröffentlicht interne Mails und
Chatnachrichten aus der Springer
Führungsetage im Mittelpunkt Matthias
töpfner der mächtige
Vorstandsvorsitzende lobt Donald Trump
äußert sich demnach aber abfällig über
Rot Grün Muslime Angela Merkel und die
Ostdeutschen insgesamt die Ossis sind
entweder Kommunisten oder Faschisten
dazwischen tun sie es nicht eklig die
Schreibweise ist original Döpfner wow
also das war ja nicht ein Zitat sondern
das war mehrere vor allen Dingen ist es
deshalb für uns zu überraschend gewesen
war ja das komplette Achse Springer
Unternehmen immer wieder versucht
auszustrahlen wir sind für ein
gemeinsames Deutschland und aus diesem
Grund ist aus meiner Sicht der als
Vorstandsvorsitz und dieses Konzerns der
eine besondere öffentliche Bedeutung
auch hat überhaupt nicht mehr tragbar
ein angefragtes Interview wollte töpfner
nicht geben am späten Nachmittag hieß es
aus der Konzernzentrale schriftlich der
heutige Artikel in der ZEIT besteht aus
persönlichen und aus jedem Zusammenhang
gerissenen Gesprächen und Chats solche
Gesprächsfetzen als öffentliches
Statements und Handlungsanweisungen
darzustellen ist falsch
die Zeit betont ihre Quellen sein
überprüft demnach forderte Döpfner von
seinen Redaktion immer wieder sich
politisch einzuwischen im
Bundestagswahlkampf 2021 schrieb er
unsere letzte Hoffnung ist die FDP nur
wenn dieser stark wird und das kann sein
wird das grünrote Disaster vermieden
diese Haltung hatte ich dann in weiten
Teilen schon für äußerst problematisch
da muss ich auch Friede Springer fragen
lassen ob sie diese polizististische
Richtung eigentlich will und ob der
töpfner da an der Stelle auch noch der
richtige Mensch ist Friede Springer die
große einflussreiche Dame des Hauses
sagte einmal Journalismus solle an der
Politik teilhaben aber keinesfalls
Politik machen das hat sich offenbar
unter Döpfner grundlegend geändert
der Tod einer Berliner Radfahrerin hat
für klimaaktivisten und AktivistInnen
der sogenannten letzten Generation keine
strafrechtlichen Konsequenzen die
Staatsanwaltschaft erklärte keine
Anklage erheben zu wollen zwar habe die
Protestaktion im Oktober auf der
Stadtautobahn die Ankunft eines
bergungsfahrzeuges am Unfallort
verzögert das Leben der Radfahrerin wäre
aber wegen ihrer Verletzungen ohnehin
nicht mehr zu retten gewesen
verantworten müssen sich die Aktivisten
allerdings wegen Nötigung und
Widerstands gegen Vollstreckungsbeamte
nach Norditalien dort hat der Tod eines
Mannes große Bestürzung hervorgerufen
der Jogger wurde von einer Beeren mit
dem Namen jj4 getötet sie ist die
Schwester von Bruno dem sogenannten
Problembären der 2006 in Bayern erlebt
worden war Italien diskutiert jetzt doch
über die Frage ob angesiedelte Bären
abgeschossen werden müssen Annette
hilsenbeck hier in den Wäldern des
Trentino in Norditalien suchen Sie nach
ihr der Bären die unter den Code jj4
registriert ist ein DNA-Abgleich brachte
den Beweis dass sie vor einer Woche den
26-Jährigen Andrea Papi beim Joggen
getötet hat
wir wissen jetzt dass eine Bärin dafür
verantwortlich ist die wir gut kennen
weil sie eine ziemlich komplizierte
Vorgeschichte hat sie waren Jahre 2020
für einen anderen Angriff verantwortlich
auf einem Berg hier in der Nähe
schon damals sollte die Bären getötet
werden
Tierschutzorganisationen verhinderten
dies per Gericht sie wurde stattdessen
eingefangen und mit einem Funk Halsband
versehen dass allerdings nicht mehr
sendet bevor sie den Jogger tötete hatte
die Bärin mehrfach Menschen attackiert
nun soll sie erlegt werden
das wieder ansiedlungsprojekt live Ursus
sei ursprünglich vor dass etwa 50 Tiere
im Trentino leben inzwischen sollen es
100 sein
da sind und die würden sich dann in
verschiedenen Alpenregionen verteilen
aber ich weiß nicht wieso sie sind alle
im Trentino geblieben
wurde nicht im Sinne des Artenschutzes
geführt sondern als eine
Touristenattraktion als wäre der Bär ein
Stofftier während haben ihre Bedürfnisse
und wir Menschen sollten uns darüber
bewusst sein
es ist eine heftige Debatte über das
Zusammenleben zwischen Mensch und Tier
derweil hat die Jagd auf die
Problembären jj4 begonnen
klare Form mutige Schnitte und kurze
Röcke dafür stand Mary Quant die heute
im Alter von 93 Jahren gestorben ist die
britische Modedesignerin machte den
Minirock populär und brachte Frauen
damit auch die Freiheit sich so
auszudrücken wie sie es wollten Thomas
konnten sie erinnern
süchtig ging es zu über zig Jahrhunderte
sittsam hatte die Frau zu sein und lang
ihr Kleid doch dann kommt sie
Modedesignerin Marie kornt greift 1962
zur Schere ein echter Einschnitt der
Minirock ist da kornt damals 32 erobert
mit ihm die Laufstege der Swinging
Sixties
und mit Hilfe des Supermodels twigi die
Modewelt und doch ist der knappe Stoff
mehr nämlich Ausdruck der weiblichen
Befreiung Mary Quandt sagt den Rückblick
die großen Veränderungen passierten
damals und die Mode und viele andere
Dinge haben davon profitiert doch
Veränderung klar Act an Korns Mini eine
maximale Provokation ein Gericht in
Chicago verbietet ihn ja bis in die 70er
Geld je weniger Stoff desto größer die
Aufregung
unverschämt ich kann vorkommen dass er
wahrscheinlich noch mehr
Unglücke passieren als sonst Kritik auch
Balkons Schöpfungen den männlichen Auge
schmeicheln freizügiger Fummel Enge in
Wahrheit ein mache die Frau zum Objekt
doch gewohnt bekommt Preise ihre
Revolution wirkt bis jetzt und öffnet
den Blick für neues gewöhnungsbedürftig
vielleicht aber Ausdruck von Freiheit
damals wie heute
und wir kommen zum Sport Sven bislang ja
eine erfolgreiche Woche für die
deutschen Tennisprofis ja das kann man
wohl sagen während die deutsche Nummer
eins alexandersverev noch auf sein
achtelfinal-match wartet hat Jan Lennart
seinen Siegeszug in Monte Carlo bereits
fortgesetzt er bezwang überraschend den
Weltranglisten 4 aus Norwegen
30-Jährige Tennis der Extraklasse Tempo
reich und druckvoll vor allem mit der
Vorhand
[Applaus]
attackiert jeden Ball mit Erfolg mit
sechs zu eins überrollt er im ersten
Satz den Favoriten im zweiten flattern
dann kurz die Nerven Stroh führt bereits
mit fünf zu zwei vergibt aber zwei
Matchbälle und lässt wieder rankommen
im Tie Break aber lässt er sich diesen
Erfolg nicht mehr nehmen 6 zu 1 und 7 zu
6 im Viertelfinale trifft morgen auf den
Russen Andrej
zum Fußball der FC Bayern München
suspendiert für das Heimspiel am Samstag
gegen Hoffenheim und verdonnert ihn zu
einer Geldstrafe im Spiel gegen ManCity
kam es zum Streit mit Leroy sané in der
Kabine soll man nie seinen Mitspieler
dann ins Gesicht geschlagen haben
noch mehr Champions League Real Madrid
steht mit einem Bein im Halbfinale der
Champions League der Titelverteidiger
besiegte den FC Chelsea zu Hause
souverän
er Carlo Ancelotti kann das Kunststück
fertig bringen seinen fünften Champions
League Titel zu holen sein Team kommt
durch Karim Benzema nach 21 Minuten zum
1:0 die Gäste von Chelsea haben auch
Chancen geraten aber nach der Pause in
Unterzahl Ben Schilder sieht rot nach
einem faul an Rodrigo
Toni groß leitet eine Viertelstunde vor
Schluss dass 20 durch Marco Asensio ein
ein souveräner Sieg doch fürs Rückspiel
ist Vorsicht geboten im Vorjahr kam real
nach klarem Hinspiel Sieg auch gegen
Chelsea nur über die Verlängerung ins
Halbfinale
und alle Highlights zur Champions League
gibt's in der ZDF heute App danke schön
und wir schauen noch auf das morgige
Wetter da gibt es große Unterschiede im
Osten für Regen im Westen für Sonne wie
das zusammenpasst das erfahren Sie
gleich von Katja hornefahrt das heute
journal läuft um 21:45 Uhr mit Dunja
Hayali und Morgen begrüßt Sie an dieser
Stelle Barbara halweg bis bald
[Musik]
guten Abend wenn ein Hoch über
Skandinavien den Thies den Weg versperrt
nach Osten dann haben die verschiedene
Möglichkeiten sie können zum Beispiel
einfach Abbremsen das hat das Tief
quacks gemacht oder sie nehmen eine ganz
besondere Zugbahn das wird hier mit
diesem kleinen tief Rudolf passiert dass
ich übergehen nur bildet und auch hier
in Deutschland für Regen und Schnee
sorgen wird Regen und Schnee fällt schon
in dieser Nacht in der Osthälfte Schnee
ist es am Alpenrand im Westen ist es
dagegen klar und so sind die
Temperaturen ganz unterschiedlich im
Westen und im Süden sinken sie auf + 3
bis -1° milder bleibt die nach dem
Nordosten bei 6 bis 3 Grad und morgen
dreht sich das Temperaturgefälle um dann
ist es nämlich im Westen am mildesten
mit höchstem Temperaturen von 12 bis 16
Grad im ostenblatt ist dagegen bei 7 bis
10 Grad doch deutlich kälter und das
liegt an den Regenwolken die sich hier
zwischen der Ostseeküste und dem
Alpenrand ausschütten und an den Alpen
ist doch morgen etwas Schnee etwas
Schneeregen dabei im Westen ist das
dagegen deutlicher vormittags kann sich
sogar mal während die Sonne zeigen das
Wochenende wird dann sehr verregnet aber
ab Montag setzt sich von Norden häufiger
die Sonne durch guten Abend